in this video you will probably see me
more frustrated than I've ever been with
this series and I honestly have no idea
how people actually feel about this Arc
as a whole I really like the first part
I had to cover last week but this week I
had to cover some tedious chapters and
from that emerge something I don't think
I like and figured it would make for an
interesting video to analyze apart from
the great soccer debate I think I've
been pretty positive about this series
but today it's time to switch things up
and chit chat about something that
really bothered me bored me and
frustrated me in this section so let's
brace ourselves and get out some popcorn
because I'm totally not Mark and this is
my continued review of the Shinobi War
Arc
[Music]
words
[Applause]
okay so over the last half a year I've
been reading the Naruto manga for the
very first time and there are a few
instances I've honestly been having a
really good experience the beginning was
a little slow but once we got to the
tune in exams things really stepped into
high gear as we were introduced to a
deep cast of characters all of which had
something to offer the story from Neji
to Rock Lee from Hinata to Shikamaru and
as time marched onward and more and more
vicious adversaries appeared and
disappeared I found myself really
getting into this series even after the
time skip where a lot of people told me
I would start to lose interest I still
found myself very much invested in
almost all of the scenes I was engaging
with until this week this week
challenged me in a way that I haven't
been challenged by a series in quite
some time and it's not a good thing as a
reviewer I never wanted to find myself
in a scenario where I had to force my
way through something in order to get it
consumed for the purposes of a review
that doesn't make for a good review and
it's unfair to the series I'm reading
too if I'm not in the right mindset for
a long story like this then even when
stuff I would otherwise enjoy prop up
I'm less likely to be charitable to it
and give it the attention it deserves
when I'm in the wrong frame of mind in
order to prevent this from happening I
take breaks during my day to walk my dog
spend some time with my family and do
some chores I'd otherwise have to do in
the evening time all in an effort to
make sure I'm receiving this material as
best I can and thankfully I've never had
to do this excessively this is all to
say that I am aware that there are
millions of fans of this section of the
story no doubt and while I still really
liked a lot of the ideas and scenes in
this section I found it to be one of the
most boring narratively to get through
and honestly it's for a number of
complicated reasons but it all boils
down to something under the umbrella of
this arc's use of flashbacks now I need
to make something perfectly clear here
before I explain because it's a lot more
complicated than just quote flashbacks
bad flashbacks are a terrific narrative
tool and just because the story uses a
ton of flashbacks in its chapters
creation doesn't by default make it an
icon received narrative creation however
I will say the effectiveness of
flashbacks heavily depends on how they
are applied within a story so again for
the people in the back of the room
flashbacks aren't the problem in
isolation here my issues lie more with
how they are being used by Kishimoto in
this Arc within stories like one piece
berserk and even Naruto itself on a
number of occasions flashbacks have been
the backbone to many iconic and terrific
scenes Itachi's impending conflict with
his brother Sasuke was a confrontation
built on the back of this particular
flashback mechanic without which the
result will be far less impressive or
impactful within that same Dynamic
Kishimoto also used The Limited
perspective of Sasuke to misdirect us
the audience through flashback to make
the climax all the more effective once
we did eventually see Itachi's
perspective and it worked brilliantly I
thought it is through understanding and
appreciating the flashback for the good
that it does within a story which
highlights I think the drawbacks to
using it flippantly or Worse again as a
narrative crutch I'm talking
specifically about the differences
between a flashback that's used to
enhance a scene versus one that is
needed for a scene to work at all and
fittingly there are examples of both in
these first three volumes of the arc so
to better illustrate my point and to
prove that I'm not just hating here here
are some instances from this section
where I really like the application of
flashbacks before we get into the
problems I have with it Naruto's
training while Naruto is all but absent
from volumes 55 and 56 he does appear
quite a lot in volumes 54 and 57 within
which we get to see his training under
killer bee to help control his Bijou
Powers more specifically to learn The
Bijou bomb which as it happens is
performed near identical fashion to the
Rasengan the very technique his father
had and that Uriah helped to teach him
there are callbacks to the Past in this
sequence which help to tie something new
the BG bomb to something emotionally
resonant from the past which had already
been previously established it helps to
heighten the sense of emotional weight
in the story while also serving to
remind us of something think we could
have conceivably known prior in other
words the flashback enhanced the moment
it did not Define the moment later in
the story Naruto is cut off from
investigating the chakra he sends
outside by iroka and others iruka is
trying to carry out what his superiors
have tasked him to do to keep Naruto on
the island but in that moment Naruto
senses the outside world and all the
suffering taking place seemingly outside
of his control it's then Kishimoto uses
flashbacks in a way that I really liked
flashing back to something that we have
seen before Naruto's final confrontation
with nagato wherein hilamenzen uses over
the futility of Warren how it
perpetuates the cycle of pain violence
and suffering in the world and in
response to itaku's request to stay put
with the promises Naruto made to nagato
echoing in his ears Naruto says I can
stop this the presence of this flashback
enhances the scene's punchline but it
doesn't depend on it and because of that
it not only helps the story feel grind
and complex but it also serves to focus
or recontextualize the point of view now
already has for us in this moment
further enhanced by yet more brief dips
into the past showing iroku's thought
process with the note he leaves Naruto
after he powers out of their grasp
speaking to their relationship this is
brilliant and heartfelt storytelling it
is exactly why I love Naruto Zabuza and
Haku Zabuza and haku's return to the
pages of this manga off the back of
their Resurrection courtesy of Kabuto is
exactly what practically all of these
fights should have been in my eyes it
feels that there are dozens of fights
that take place in this Arc very few of
which I actually cared about but this
was one I very much found not only
enjoyable but powerful with them begging
to be put out of their misery to Kakashi
they slowly lose themselves as pawns yet
again to the elites that control them
zombies to the violent World they've
been forced in many ways to participate
in continuing the cycle of violence and
suffering that nagato spoke of and that
Naruto is currently trying to stop
despite being very early established
characters with little screen time they
end up painting a clear picture of
precisely the world or heroes in this
story are trying to change regarding
flashbacks however there's only minor
pieces of exposition of which there are
some minor pieces to remind us who these
people are in case we've forgotten it
doesn't distract from or bloat their
presence at all I Zuma versus Ino
Shikamaru and choji this is another
fight I enjoy part of but then started
to see a pattern emerge an obvious
pattern that slowly devolved into a
tedious nightmare for me okay I'm being
a little hyperbolic but it's all just
for good fun and it's a comic after all
come on Ino Shikamaru and Shoji's
efforts against Azuma are some of the
most emotional out of all the conflicts
that take place here for me the
struggles that each member deals with
are the clear highlights that further
speak to the themes of generational
inheritance tsukumaru spoke of a while
back in the story The Next Generation is
taking over and accepting the new
position as Legends in their own right
by taking down the current Legends or
Legends of the past flashbacks are
heavy-handed in this scene too one in
particular that works well I thought is
the flashback to assume his parenting
advice to his students it's touching and
serves to put the scene on a pedestal in
my eyes a powerful strong moment choji
struggles to apply himself honestly
Shikamaru has an incredible amount of
resolve and conviction in this moment
having the clarity of mind to remind
Shoji that they are fighting to protect
asuma's child from his now zombified
father that they can't afford to be
cowardly in this moment which sort of
bounces off of a line concerning
conviction from another fight that I'll
touch on slightly more negatively later
on but you know the quotes from that
section are still really good this is
all to say that Kishimoto had some
really cool ideas here and executed upon
some of them perfectly fine and well in
my mind but my god did I think that this
section was a structural nightmarish
Quagmire that I had to stop reading on
countless occasions because I was just
so sick of hearing Exposition from
characters I knew were going to go away
in mere chapters and that's not to even
make mention of a particular use of
flashbacks he employs here too before I
begin I think it's important to state
that I don't think Kishimoto is
necessarily using flashbacks as a crutch
per se but they're definitely doing a
lot of the heavy lifting during these
scenes and chapters over and over again
and I think that's the most important
part making up for a potential lack of
personal investment between his audience
and the characters a potential
unfamiliarity between his audience and
these characters seeing as they show up
very little in the story in meaningful
ways and perhaps a lack of planning or
proper structuring for these encounters
ahead of time on behalf of Kishimoto for
the better part of two volumes I spend
so much time with characters I either
didn't know didn't care about or with
one group did care about but didn't love
the execution of kinkaku and ginkaku for
instance I have never heard of before so
in order to create a scenario with a
satisfying climax to this section
Kishimoto uses a flashback to establish
something in the past for these
characters to call back to in the end of
the fight before they're defeated to
give its ending an air of I don't know
finality otherwise it would have just
felt weird and using this technique here
and there you know it's honestly fine
but here's the thing he uses this exact
same technique back to back to back in
this Arc it feels like this drab dude
durai I think his name is d-u-r-a-i has
a flashback informing me or reminding me
of him and sets up the conclusion to his
fight mifune vs Hanzo have some nice
themes that play with some great quotes
that I mentioned before but ultimately I
do not care about these characters and
again kishimono uses yet more Flags
specs to create quote satisfying
conclusions here for these people and
even during the Asuma fight which
focused on suji this is by far the least
offensive by the way but it still had
yet another flashback to something we
could have already seen before but never
did and the fact is that it's there to
set up a climax for me that cheapens
what was already emotionally resonant
without it and heck maybe they did talk
about the earrings before but if they
did I honestly could recall which just
makes me wish that these characters had
more of a central role in the story
because they are compelling now the use
of a flashback here I think in isolation
is perfectly fine but within this
Twisted Meandering never-ending Conga
line of now boring flashbacks this
particular attempt to reach me
emotionally absolutely fell flatter than
it should which is as I said such a
shame because I actually really like
joji and look I really wanted to fill
this video with more positivity than
there ultimately will be here and there
will be positivity for sure in places
but when I was going through my notes
for this let me just say that there were
a lot of heated words used one of the
worst things the story can be for me
personally is boring if something is
comically bad at least I can laugh at it
and have a good time engagement and
interest is the most important aspect of
this process and I just didn't get a
whole lot of that in this section
unfortunately with that said let's press
on to something I did like a lot more at
the beginning of volume 57 the story
starts to refocus itself on the main
characters yet again thankfully and
Kishimoto says as much in an almost
exasperated blurb at the start of the
volume 2. as I've said in the past
eightier Aura is fantastic at tying
together seemingly disconnected prior
encounters to heighten the stakes or
emotional weight of a present scene and
while I don't think Kishimoto is
comparably strong in that department he
is extremely good at communicating his
experiences and feelings through his
analog in this story Naruto there's this
dope one-on-one scene where Naruto gets
to meet and Converse with the
nine-tailed fox spirit yet again the fox
brings up his past with Sasuke saying
that he couldn't even protect him from
his own hatred and yet he thinks he can
save everyone from it in the throes of
war and again this internal conflict
with Naruto has been a fun and
compelling device to demonstrate the
growth of the character throughout this
journey in the beginning he didn't even
want to face him or look at him he was
terrified of it he tried to feign
confidence and eventually he gave into
it before his parents lifted him out on
two separate occasions however this time
Naruto reaffirms that he hasn't failed
with Sasuke because the only way to fail
in this instance would be to quit and he
will never quit on his friends which is
a terrific answer brimming with charm
and courage for Naruto to say all the
while he looks at his evil self's
reflection in the eye of the fox
speaking to his overcoming of his inner
demons indirectly answering the question
the fox asked the first place of his
sudden confidence boost it's a terrific
scene All Things Considered furthermore
on the positive side of things we get my
favorite scene I've covered in this
video so far and while I'm sure many of
you will find it quite unremarkable the
very fact it was different from all the
other scenes I've seen up until now was
enough to sway me in a positive
direction let that sink in it was
different and therefore I liked it a lot
Switching gears from the constant
fighting and flashbacks we get this
rather intense scene where an imposter
posing as Neji appears in the medic tent
area alongside the likes of Sakura it's
honestly an interesting ruffle to the
story to help add some variety while
also giving Sakura more to do which is
awesome it's a rather simple angle with
a lot of consequence that really changes
up the formula from a more
combat-centric approach to a more
thriller-based strategic one honestly I
thought this was one of the coolest
ideas in the arc so far and very
creative trying to weed out the spies in
their midst really helped to make this
battle feel much less shallow than it
otherwise it felt up until now it's a
plotline that's completely different and
demonstrates front and center the
variance and application of the
different forms of Jutsu
what are you doing do you think we
should pick him up
he's got a knife but he's got G fuel and
a knife I'm sure there's a reason
hey buddy
what's with a knife
it's for uh
makes it
happen
hey he's got cheese here nah he's got
[ __ ] his two knives
the Roy kage vs Naruto scene was a
really cool initial scrimmers to show
some of Naruto's abilities in his I
don't know Spirit State I don't know the
name for that we need to look it up
the nine-tailed chakra form and
furthermore did a great job of
reaffirming his convictions and points
of view to us as readers claiming that
his father made absolutely no mistakes
when he believed in what he Naruto was
able to do and just when things are
getting good we get another flashback
this time for killerby I do like that it
demonstrated the relationship between
Killer B and the network and I really
liked his interaction with Naruto's dad
and how that informs his decision at the
very end forcing Naruto to prove himself
to him by making him Dodge his fastest
attack it really speaks to the phrase
real gold doesn't fear trial by fire for
if Naruto is the savior he espouses to
be then nothing not even the fastest in
the land could stand in his way and it
doesn't
look I'm willing to concede right off
the bat that this probably has an
explanation that someone much more
informed about the series can answer but
when this dude inoichi called upon
Naruto for a quick hello I honestly got
confused was this something that they
were always able to do naturally a level
of suspension of disbelief is required
and I had applied that to the legions of
people they had been in communication
with in the battlefield in my mind it
was conceivable that they had arranged
some sort of frequency or item to be
held or something to differentiate them
from everyone else otherwise they'd just
be able to talk all the time to anyone
they wanted which would be by extension
make all the times people go missing in
this series make a lot less sense but
then he calls up Naruto to fill him in
on the plot Exposition he needs and
pieces out quickly afterwards while
Naruto is conceivably a great distance
away moving at incredibly high speeds
and wasn't part of the military's plan
at all Beyond staying put in a hole in
the ground hiding why wasn't this used
to try and communicate with Sasuke right
after he left why wasn't it used when
whenever Naruto went missing or when
Sakura went missing is it like Dragon
Ball when people hide their Chi or in
this case chakra it's like blocking
their number from being called and if
that's the case did Sasuke just not use
any chakra for the three years he was
training again I'm not sure if this is
actually an issue or if I'm just missing
something if I am missing something let
me know in the comments down below
respectively I I really don't know there
must be something I'm missing here
that's quite substantial and I hope
someone can clear this up for me because
right now it seems really weird
[Music]
earlier in the story we were presented
once again with Gara on the front lines
awaiting the arrival of four resurrected
Shinobi and we were told one of them is
gara's father I was excited for gar to
play a large role in the story given his
position and the Mystery surrounding his
origin still largely unknown to us
outside of a flashback here and there
but once we eventually did catch back up
with him we got maybe two or three
chapters exploring his origin with yet
more flashbacks and to be honest the
flashback was inoffensive and worked
well enough but the entire thing felt
like it was massively rushed to me and
due to the absurd amount this act relies
on flashbacks to conclude story beats
when I saw the black Pages emerge yet
again for this section's flashback I
started to roll my eyes unfortunately
again not because flashbacks are bad but
because the way that they are using this
Arc now is very tedious I can predict
where things are going to go narratively
it now takes all the suspense out of the
occasion and feels like it's kishimoto's
way of Expediting the process of telling
these minor stories and it's frustrating
because again like joji I really like
Gara as a character and a lot of these
ideas here seem like they could have
been much more effective if presented
with a little more pre-planning like
Rock Lee choji and so many others I wish
I got to see more of Gara in this series
but we really haven't gotten a chance to
see him that much up until now and so to
make up for that kishimonu uses these
flashbacks to create this sense of a
more detailed and comprehensive
backstory to all of these interactions
however in doing so this often it just
feels like he's making stuff up on the
spot in a haphazard fashion and I'm sure
he isn't also and this is just a minor
nitpick but I just thought it was funny
chapter 548 is entitled Naruto vs Itachi
again I was excited because that's a
pretty impressive title but 98 of the
chapter is about the resolution to
gara's conflict only in the last two
pages of the chapter do Naruto and
Itachi even appear and in those two
final Pages they don't even speak to
each other why call it Naruto versus
Tachi there's nothing about it that
remotely shows these two in Conflict
okay okay front over gotta chill the
story surrounding this character does
continue somewhat as he contributes
greatly in aiding Naruto in the takedown
of one of the resurrected kage and while
I still love Gara and thought his
contributions throughout this Arc had
some great ideas behind them I just
found the manner with which they were
presented to be a little on the
predictable formulaic and boring sight
of things regretfully Itachi on the
other hand was the first sign I got that
things were turning themselves around in
this story and boy did they his meeting
with Naruto is less about them fighting
each other but more of them coming to
understand one another and Itachi
feeling comfortable enough to entrust
Naruto with his brother the scene is
filled with a lot of cool stuff I
particularly enjoyed the notion that
Hitachi left a Raven as a contingency
within Naruto based on what he suspected
Sasuke to do after he died I mean that's
a 4D level chess move If Ever I did C1
and totally something I'd expect from
someone like Itachi to do and to that
end I really like the psychological
angle he took when Naruto insisted on
shouldering all of this responsibility
however between this Hitachi stuff and
the next hype moment I will say that I
wasn't all too enthused or entertained
with the numerous cutaways to various
different former kage now resurrected
for the purposes of conflict titles on
their own don't really mean anything to
me and if I don't understand who someone
is on any level prior to my meeting them
convincing me to care in the middle of
the very battle they were participating
in is like trying to convince your date
to go out with you while you're in the
middle of said date it's kind of put in
the cart before the horse there that
said I did enjoy the short scene Naruto
shares with the third right Kai guys
almost impenetrable defenses cleverly
utilizing his own durability and power
against himself it's such a Naruto
strategy blunt but effective and well
paneled 2 money I'd buy Kishimoto with
all of that said as we Flash from one
area of conflict to the next the pace
starts to Quicken when the main point of
Interest arrives
arrives in the scene in a resurrected
body and decides that it's time to start
making things really fun again I'm
serious from this point on I pretty much
loved everything it's like the story
went from a 4 out of 10 to an 8 in a
matter of a couple of chapters with some
of them even reaching as high as 9.5s
later in my estimation and I absolutely
will be talking more about that later on
I really liked this fight along with
many of the others required Naruto to
find a balance in sharing the burden of
this battle at hand particularly within
himself as I've mentioned before the
internal struggle for Naruto contending
with the fox bear has been looming in
the background of most every dangerous
encounter he's engaged with either as a
risk he's needed to contend with or the
very cause for that very conflict that's
occurring in that moment the fight with
uchiya Madara has a powerful heir to it
the likes of which I haven't felt since
Itachi for some reason I wasn't really
expecting him to prop up in the story
like this but in hindsight it makes a
lot of sense considering what we've seen
thus far from this story with all the
resurrected Warriors but what makes this
fight scene all the more intimidating is
the Foxberry its willingness to
earnestly help Naruto in battle just
because he's sort of intimidated by
moderate potentially even fearful it's
absolutely a turning point in the story
and one that elevates the antagonist
here in ways that we have never seen
before from this scene there are a lot
of cool moments obviously the meteor is
a big one that comes to mind but one
that stands out to me is the unification
of all five kages in the effort against
Madonna and furthermore I really like
how they all sort of had their own roles
with the obvious being tsunade's healing
abilities acting as support and Roy kage
acting as I don't know the muscle once
this whole thing kicks off and a couple
of them fire attacks towards Madara only
for him to be unimpressed and say things
like it's not even worth absorbing for
him then to get absolutely decked hard
by the raikage it was massively
entertaining and cathartic it's no
longer a battle to protect Naruto but
instead want to protect each other
villagers that were once at each other's
throats thanks to a common enemy have
gained a sense of solidarity and
Community something they wish to now
fight for it [ __ ] brilliant I
honestly flipped out with what this led
to the best part of the arc this is in
my opinion without question the best
part of this Arc by a country mile so
much so that it almost completely makes
up for the more boring Parts I've
experienced in this story with a truly
powerful moment coming by way of Naruto
communicating his values and intentions
effectively to the spirits he's trying
to reach most specifically to the one
that has been a source of Torment for
him his entire life at numerous times
during this section I lost my Collective
[ __ ] and could not stop reading and on
top of all of that from a visual
perspective this is the best the manga
has looked in God knows how long while
the moderate stuff was fantastic and
very enjoyable it's in that exact moment
from when Naruto's perspective shifts
from the five kages that I ended up
getting one of the biggest shots the
series has ever given me
he [ __ ] headbutts him straight away
and by the way this is my new favorite
panel from the manga it's awesome and
super surprising with just the right
amount of silly with these two
characters having always been separated
in some shape or form to see them Clash
together so suddenly and
unconventionally it actually got me to
recoil my chair and Shout out and draw
upon me the watchful judging eyes of my
wife it's okay I explained the situation
in the story and she patted me on the
head before leaving for her mums and not
but look at Naruto's expression on this
manga page it's so kinetic I love it
matara reveals that he's someone by the
name of Toby in the same great great
great and also nobody reaffirming his
conviction and achieving his goal of
effectively brainwashing the entire
world into peace and with this group of
seemingly zombified jinjuriki carrying
out madara's Mission being Naruto the
only remaining jinchuriki left have
their backs up against a wall
[Music]
see what I mean about this section just
being awesome and the artwork we're
reading this moment in the manga is
amazing too again more terrific artwork
from Kishimoto and even more surprises
that I never saw coming and naturally
when these two show up to fight against
Madara I lost it again we've suddenly
left all of these fights I never really
had any investment in and now we're
finally focusing on some of the most
hyped moments I've come across in a long
long while within this series and
something I need to make clear here too
while there are some Trudy breathtaking
moments depicted in this section with
regards to its action this still isn't
my favorite part of the material
contained in this section and
furthermore the material that I think is
the best has little to do at all with
action
foreign
the Journey of Naruto across this entire
story has been about how he himself has
been impacted by the circumstances of
his own birth he's been shunned
ostracized and bullied for effectively
being a vessel for something he never
accepted in the first place to Naruto he
was in a horribly unfortunate situation
because there was something wrong with
him and when he did eventually find out
I could well imagine there being a level
of resentment attached to that too a
profound feeling of why me or there's
this monster inside of me and now I have
to pay for it and to a varying degree is
some more extreme than others this has
unfortunately been the case and on this
long and sprawling quest to achieve his
dreams he's also had to search for who
he is made evidence through interactions
with Gara nagato and others Naruto has
expressed that had things developed
differently in his life he could have
been consumed by hatred much like these
guys could have been too the fox Spirit
itself is shown up in the story a great
number of times at first as a monster
shocking and scaring the young Naruto
and over the course of his life through
misdirection and in some ways taking
advantage of the young man's greatest
insecure this Spirit has tried to free
himself from the prison by leveraging
the hate inside Naruto's psyche however
thanks to some support from his friends
mentors and indeed even his parents
Naruto has not only managed to become a
well-rounded individual but one that has
managed to overcome his metaphorical
inner demon with only one thing left in
his way his literal inner demon this Arc
made a curious choice of adding
considerably more opportunities for
Kurama the foxbeared inside Naruto to
characterize himself Beyond simply being
an antagonistic monster and truthfully
at first I thought this was a little too
fast or premature however the necessary
precedent for this section had already
been laid thanks to killer be and his
biju's relationship and as the story
progresses we come to learn that much
like Naruto urama has much like all the
other Bijou severe trust issues when it
comes to dealing with humans and with
good reason there are some cute
references to Dragon Ball and Journey to
the West with The Monkey King 2 but why
this works so effectively is that what
convinces Kurama isn't anything Naruto
says much like everything in his life
it's never been his words that have
carried him to where he is today it's
the actions he takes and In This Moment
Naruto proves himself to the fox by
freeing his fellow Bijou in a selfless
effort however now in desperate need of
chakra Kurama finally makes the decision
that he seemingly never has before
[Music]
[Applause]
this looked awesome holy wow okay so the
visual here I love it having spent a
considerable amount of time reminiscing
over Naruto's life there's such a
wonderful contrast between this the fox
Spirit state that he's in currently and
say this this weird demon mode that he
was in Prior once a child with something
deep inside him scratching and clawing
their way out fighting over his body and
now a freed Spirit fighting alongside
Naruto in harmony I'm Gonna Leave This
here for now but my overall thoughts on
this particular choice is that of all
and curiosity now that the fox has been
freed does that mean that the end game
here is to eventually release all the
Bijou back into the wild to live freely
again or is the end game going to be
something along the lines of what Killer
B has with his Bijou as a standard
moving forward it's strange and that's
not even to make mention of this
murderer or Toby situation I'll be
continuing this story and my coverage of
it next week and sharing my Impressions
then so please consider subscribing if
you don't want to miss it until then
I've been told you not Mark and thank
you so much for watching
[Music]